avec well and Frot bonjour Hélène
bonjour Pauline l'entrée réussie donc
des Bleus dans cette Coupe du Monde et
l'équipe de France qui s'est imposée
face à l'Australie hier soir 4-1 malgré
les détections de Benzema Kanté et Pogba
et malgré une grosse frayeur en début de
match les Bleus commencent effectivement
finalement plutôt bien cette compétition
au grand soulagement de la presse
hexagonale ils sont là s'enthousiasme
Midi Libre satisfait de voir les Bleus
prendre seul la tête de leur groupe D
après le match nul d'hier entre la
Tunisie et le Danemark auteur vous
l'avez dit d'un doublé Olivier Giroud
lance l'équipe de France a lieu l'Alsace
qui précise que l'attaquant du Milan AC
rejoint Thierry Henry en tête du
classement des meilleurs buteurs de
l'histoire de l'équipe de France avec 51
buts Olivier Giroud qu'on retrouve à la
une de l'équipe en voyant un baiser vers
le ciel pour le quotidien sportif le
Numéro 9 a non seulement rej Thierry
Henri au panthéon des Bleus mais
également assis pour de bon sa
légitimité à la pointe de l'équipe de
France et viser enfin une phase finale
digne de son statut fin de citation en
revanche le ciel hélène est tombé sur la
tête de la sélection argentine
surprise de l'Argentine face à l’arabie
Saoudite 2 buts à un et vécu comme un
véritable drame national d'après Clarine
tout le pays est passé de l'euphorie à
la déception et le quotidien à argentin
Pauline n'est pas très optimiste pour la
suite rappelant qu'il est arrivé
seulement quatre fois dans l'histoire de
la Coupe du monde que des équipes ayant
perdu leur premier match parviennent
ensuite à atteindre la finale une seule
d'entre elles ayant réussi à décrocher
le titre olé quotidien sportif argentin
n'en revient toujours pas des mots clés
de cette incroyable titre ce matin le
journal on évoquant une équipe sous le
choc a commencé par son capit Lionel
Messi qui a dit se sentir dévasté je le
cite par cette déroute le vainqueur de
la Copa América 2021 elle n'était pas
prêt à encaisser une telle défaite
d'après et le païs qui évoque la
médecine dépendance de l'alby Céleste
l'Argentine se croyait invincible car
elle avait construit une équipe pour
Lionel Messi elle aurait mieux fait de
demander quelle équipe exigeait la
présence d'un leader aussi particulier
que mes six critiques le quotidien
espagnol pour le libanais Hassan blables
la défaite d'hier remarquerait plutôt le
crépuscule du roi Messi représenté ici
en roi soleil déclinant un des saints
publiés par le site cartoon movement en
Arabie Saoudite en revanche la victoire
a donné lieu à des explosions de joie
ce paie même le luxe d'ironisé ce matin
à la Une donc cry for me Argentina comme
dans la comédie musicale et Vita le
quotidien saoudien nous annonce que le
roi Salman a décidé pour l'occasion
d'approuver la suggestion que lui a
faite le prince héritier Mohamed Ben
Salman d'offrir un jour férié
aujourd'hui pour toutes les personnes
vivantes et travaillantes en Arabie
Saoudite voilà pour les réjouissances
côté court côté jardin et beaucoup plus
discrètement le royaume vient d'exécuter
Pauline 12 personnes en 10 jours il se
dirige vers un nouveau record un nombre
record d'exécution cette année c'est ce
que rappelle le Courrier International
qui cite ici plusieurs sources
britanniques notamment de Times d'après
le journal les exécutions de ces
derniers jours seraient liées à la fin
d'un moratoire non-officiel depuis 2020
dans l'application de la peine de mort
pour des crimes liées à la drogue
Courrier International fait aussi état
des inquiétudes concernant à
ressortissants jordanien ou scène abo
alril emprisonné depuis 8 ans sans avoir
jamais eu recours à un avocat accès à un
avocat et détenu dans le couloir de la
mort
justement un trafic de drogue à la suite
qui aura été à la suite d'aveu qui aura
été fait sous la torture selon l'ONG de
défense des droits de l'Homme we prive
inquiétude aussi Hélène sur les risques
de représailles à l'égard des membres de
l'équipe de foot iranienne on s'en
souvient c'était il y a quelques jours
des joueurs qui ont refusé de chanter
l'hymne national lors de leur premier
match toujours à la Coupe du Monde de
gardien fait état de la fureur des
cadres du régime notamment du président
du conseil municipal de Téhéran qui a
déclaré Jules que personne ne serait
plus autorisée à insulter l'hymne et le
drapeau iranien le journal rappelle que
le silence des joueurs a été perçu comme
une manifestation de soutien envers les
protestataires anti régimes dans un
contexte de répression accrue en
particulier au Kurdistan iranien le
mécontentement des mots là évoqués aussi
dans ce dessin de peterbrooks publié
notamment sur Twitter où on voit les
dirigeants iraniens armes à la fusil
d'assaut cordes matraque et fouet
proposé au joueur de l'équipe nationale
d'apprendre à chanter leur hymne iranien
en parfaite harmonie on ne se quitte pas
là dessus avant de vous dire à tout à
l'heure Pauline je vous propose de jeter
un style à l'humanité qui fait état
d'une proposition de loi qui sera
présentée demain à l'Assemblée et qui
déclenche les passions ici en France une
proposition de loi pour interdire la
corrida cette tradition des chaînes
littéralement les passions au point de
diviser au sein même des partis
politiques d'après l'Huma l'importance
prise par ce débat ou plutôt le pugilat
auquel il donne lieu interroge cependant
le Figaro qui se demande s'il est
députés n'ont pas mieux à faire que de
débattre de la corridas qui n'empêche
pas de dérouler les arguments des uns et
des autres ceux des défenseurs de la
corrida qui estiment qu'elle n'a rien à
voir avec le sadisme que c'est une
culture un patrimoine une sociabilité
bien des régions françaises et qu'il
importe de la préserver et puis ceux des
adversaires de la corrida qui jugent que
c'est un acte de cruauté et rappelle que
le papi 5 lui-même avait déjà manifesté
son opposition à la corrida au 16e
siècle et vous Pauline qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez j'ai pas d'avis en
revanche j'ai je voulais vous parler de
du fait que la corrida avait inspiré la
chanson française de variétés l'un de
ses plus grands tubes n'est-ce pas
signer Francis Cabrel merci beaucoup
Hélène et on va continuer à parler de
musique